- Jordan Peterson came to Senate
lunch about half a year ago
and the point he made was
conservatives were just terrible
at defending
conservative values.
Then he granted us
immediate absolution,
he said because we never
thought we'd have to.
Whoever thought we'd have
to defend the benefit
of having a mom and a dad?
Listen, there are
other ways, okay,
but can we at least
acknowledge it's really nice
for children to have a father
who provides discipline
and the mother that, again,
that's a good arrangement.
It's stood the test of time.
We never thought we'd
have to defend that.
We never thought our daughters
would have to compete
against biological
males, then be expected
to take a shower in
the same locker room,
and then have a judge
order the biological male
to take showers in the
girls' locker room.
Never thought we'd be pushing
back on school administrators
that want to administer
gender blocking drugs
to our children and
not tell the parents.
(mysterious music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
we are once again in DC,
and joining me today is
the Republican senator
representing the great
state of Wisconsin,
Senator Ron Johnson.
Finally, welcome to
"The Rubin Report".
- Hello Dave.
Well, I appreciate
you having me on.
- Think I've had
basically everybody.
You're a rookie on
"The Rubin Report".
- Didn't realize
I was so elusive.
- Well, I told you
right before we started
you have nothing to fear
because I am unvaxxed,
and this has become one
of your hardcore things,
what has happened
with these vaccines.
- Well, it's tragic
what's happened.
The pandemic has exposed so
many problems in this country,
the capture by big pharma of
our federal health agencies,
but also of the media
and the big tech
social media giants as well.
And the American public has
not been given the truth.
The agencies have
not been transparent.
The big pharma companies
haven't been transparent.
And I'm certainly
not an anti-vaxxer,
but based on what's
happened here,
I've certainly started asking
a whole lot more questions.
- So when you ask
those questions,
specifically in the hearings
here at the Capitol,
and you know, the Congressmen
and senators get out there,
it seems like we
catch people in lies
and Fauci will be caught
saying we didn't do
gain of function, we
did, I didn't say masks,
I did, et cetera, et cetera.
I think one thing that
people are getting
very frustrated with
now is it doesn't seem
like anyone pays a
price at the end.
Nobody gets fired, nobody
gets removed from their job.
It's like we live in this
time of cancel culture.
We'll cancel a
comedian for a joke,
and yet the people
that are really doing
some nefarious stuff,
it's almost irrelevant.
- Well, as it relates to the
pandemic and the coronavirus,
you've got the COVID cartel,
and that is the
Biden administration,
the federal health
agencies, big pharma,
then the legacy media and the
big tech social media giants.
There you go, there's
the COVID cartel.
They're the ones collectively
that sabotaged early treatment.
I can't tell you the exact
moment the decision was made
that the only solution
to the pandemic
was gonna be vaccines,
vaccines, vaccines.
And as a result, you better
not have any therapies
because it might
be difficult to get
an emergency use authorization
if there is those
types of therapies.
- Because you
actually can't, right?
Technically you can't
get the emergency use.
- Well, again, you
know, in Washington DC
there are rules until
people don't want
to follow the rules, right?
But the fact of the matter
is I totally believe
the doctors who say that
hundreds of thousands of people
lost their lives
that didn't have to
because they weren't
being treated early.
And it is bizarre.
I'm almost 68 years old.
As long as I've been
alive, the medical advice
has always been early detection
allows for early treatment
produces better results, right?
We do that with everything.
That's why we try and go in
there and detect cancers early,
so we can treat them.
But not with COVID.
But we were happy to spend
tens of billions of dollars
on tests, and we did spend
on tests, and you can argue
about the PCR tests, okay.
And then so what
good did that do?
I mean, once the horse
is out of the barn
and the cat was out of the bag,
we weren't stopping the spread,
so the testing didn't
stop the spread.
Then we told people,
well don't do anything.
Go home, be afraid,
isolate yourself.
Hope you don't get
so sick that you have
to check yourself in the
hospital where they'll inject
about 3000 bucks worth
of Remdesivir in your arm
that might take out your
kidneys, put you on a vent.
80 to 90% of the people that
were put on a ventilator
never came off it, not alive.
This was insane what we did.
And I'm thoroughly
convinced that this,
I always call it a cornucopia
full of widely available
proven safe generic
drugs used both on label
and off label, they worked.
I had enough people come to me,
I could refer them to doctors.
I followed up on the case,
and some remarkable results.
But it's all being denied.
Now, they're doctoring
different studies,
under powering, for example,
the use of Ivermectin.
They give it for three
days on an empty stomach
well into the course
of your disease.
I mean, it's sick when you're
aware of what's happening here
and how the COVID cartel
continues to cover up
for its miserably failed
response to COVID.
But again, the body
count is way too high.
They can't admit they are wrong,
and I just described
who's in the COVID cartel.
They have the power to
make it almost impossible
to prove them wrong.
So that's why they're
out taking away people's,
doctor's certification
that had the courage
and compassion to treat COVID.
They're destroying these
people, they're vilifying them.
It's sick.
- So is there anything
we can do about it?
I mentioned to you
right before we started,
I saw you a few weeks
ago at Governor DeSantis,
he's doing these
blueprint events.
I think the one that we were
at was an education one,
but he's done one on
COVID, he's got this panel.
It seems to me some
states might start doing
some things, but maybe
at the federal level,
the ship is out.
- Well, you know what a
lonely voice I am here
in Washington DC.
Most of my colleagues
pushed the vaccine
on their constituents.
They don't want to
admit they were wrong.
Doctors don't want to
Again, the COVID cartel will
never admit they're wrong.
So the only solution I have here
is uncovering and
exposing the truth,
and that's what I'm
dedicated to doing.
I held, you can't call them
hearings, they're events.
I did that after I
lost my chairmanship.
Now, as a chairman,
this is odd too.
Nobody else was holding
hearings on early treatment.
I'm the guy that
holds a hearing, first
of all in February,
a roundtable with Scott
Gottlieb and found out
we don't make drugs here.
We spent trillions of dollars.
We didn't solve that problem.
We wouldn't spend a dime on
on-shoring drug manufacturing.
May of 2020, I held a
hearing with John Ioannidis
trying to put things
in perspective.
You know, he did the analysis
of the Princess cruise,
which pretty well has stood
the test of time now, right?
The infection mortality rate
of COVID for anybody under 70
is actually less than
a bad flu season, okay?
This was not a disease
that we should have been
freaking out about.
Yes, serious if you're elderly,
if you had certain
comorbidities,
but we never should have
shut the economy down.
So I held that hearing
in May of 2020.
I also had Pierre Kory there
talking about corticosteroids.
He was savaged on
that until, well,
all of a sudden a UK
study with dexamethasone,
which is a corticosteroid,
proved those were effective.
Had the hearing with Peter
McCullough and George Fareed
and Harvey Risch on early
treatment in November.
We were labeled the snake
oil salesmen of the Senate
by Dr. Jha, who never
treated a COVID patient.
Followed that up with a
hearing with Pierre Kory
on Ivermectin.
Then I got connected with the
vaccine injured community,
held events.
Okay, now I don't
have the power.
But anyway, those
early hearings,
those weren't conducted
by the health committees.
I was doing that as Chairman
of Homeland Security
and Governmental Affairs.
Again, I thought
this was insane.
They were shutting
down our economy,
but everybody seemed to
be on board with that.
- Did you feel that
really from day one,
because I always say to
people, and as I mentioned,
I'm unvaxxed, I've
become sort of,
I'm not an unvaxxer
in, as you said,
in that traditional
sense of the phrase,
but once they started
with mandates,
and after two weeks,
to me that was it.
Once the two weeks became
15 days, I was like,
uh-uh, something else
is going on here.
Were you feeling that
really from day one?
- Well, as soon
as I heard about-
- Because I grant
everybody a certain leash
at the beginning.
- I don't expect
you follow my clips,
but I'm the guy who said,
probably in March of 2020,
it wasn't March, that
listen, we tragically lose
36,000 people a
year on the highway,
but we don't shut
our highways down.
We need a transportation system.
We can't shut the economy down.
We can't shut it down.
Fauci heard that comment,
said I was way out there.
No, it was actually a
pretty good analogy.
We never should have
shut our economy down,
not even for a couple of weeks.
Again, I understand
the fear back then,
and maybe that's what
separated me from others.
- [Dave] Well, that's
why I'm asking.
- I wasn't freaked about this.
I was concerned.
I mean, you see the
folks in moon suits,
doctors treat COVID patients,
they're dropping like flies.
Yeah, it was something
to be concerned about.
But once John Ioannidis
did that analysis
on the Princess cruise, that
certainly calmed me down.
But I also, I understood the
reality of the situation.
You can't shut the economy down.
And look at how we shut it down.
Let liquor stores open,
shut down churches.
Shut down all the mom and
pop Main Street businesses,
let the big box stores open.
I mean, this was sick.
Bobby Kennedy writes in
his "A Letter to Liberals",
he quotes a study
conducted in 2021,
said there was about a $4
trillion transfer of wealth
from the middle class to the
big tech social media giants.
Gee, why were they
censoring information?
Why were they pushing shutdowns
and be so supportive of,
again, what I always
call our miserable,
our miserably failed
response to COVID?
- Right, and basically
we're all sitting at home
ordering everything on
Amazon instead of going
to the few mom and pop stores
that might have fought it.
- So by shutting
down our economy,
by printing
trillions of dollars,
I mean, the economic
devastation of the pandemic
and how we mishandled
it, I mean, I don't know
that we'll ever really fully
dig ourselves out of it.
And then the human toll too.
I mean, people died
that didn't have to die.
- You mentioned following
some of your clips.
You had a clip about
two months ago now
on "Meet the Press"
with Chuck Todd
where he was going after you,
and you really threw
it back to him.
So I'm gonna throw to the clip.
- Do you have a crime that you
think Hunter Biden committed,
because I have yet to
see anybody explain.
It is not a crime to make
money off your last name.
- So Chuck, you ought to
read the Marco Polo report,
where they detail all
kinds of potential crimes,
you know, Senator Grassley
certainly uncovered.
- Oh, let me just
stop you there.
Potential.
Senator, potential is innuendo.
That's why you do
an investigation.
- I mean, Chuck, is it
a crime to be soliciting
and purchasing
prostitution in potentially
European sex
trafficking operations?
Is that a crime?
Because Chuck Grassley
and I laid out
about $30,000 paid by
Hunter Biden to those types
of individuals over December
2018/2019, about $30,000.
This is about the same
time that President Biden
offered to pay about $100,000
of Hunter Biden's bills.
Again, that's just
some information.
I don't know exactly
if there's a crime.
It doesn't really, look, it
sounds sleazy as you know.
- I'll take you at your word
that you're ethically
bothered by Hunter Biden.
I'm curious though, you
seem to have a pattern.
- Are you not?
Are you not?
Chuck, you know,
part of the problem,
and this is pretty obvious
to anybody watching this,
is you don't invite
me on to interview me,
you invite me on
to argue with me.
You know, I'm just trying
to lay out the facts
that certainly Senator
Grassley and I uncovered.
They were suppressed,
they were censored.
They interfered in
the 2020 election.
Conservatives understand that.
Unfortunately, liberals
in the media don't,
and that's part of the reasons
our politics are inflamed,
is we do not have
an unbiased media.
We don't.
It's unfortunate.
I'm all for free press.
It needs to be more unbiased.
- It seems like you like
fighting people on television.
You were ready, you were ready.
- I kind of like to argue.
Yeah, you know, unfortunately
in America today
we don't have an unbiased media.
We don't have
journalists anymore,
we have advocates for the left.
You know, Chuck Todd doesn't
invite me on to interview me,
he invites me on to argue
with me or set me up,
you know, use me as a foil
to make his leftist point.
You know, that was
two years since I had
a similar situation with
him after January 6th,
where he said, you know,
I think he accused me,
Senator, you're lighting the
fuse, you're starting the fire.
No, Chuck, you
are, you are, okay?
- Yeah, exactly.
- And it's true.
I mean, four years
conservative had to watch
the Russian hoax,
where, let's face it,
the media set aside any
pretense of being unbiased,
and they said, no,
we can't be unbiased
because we've got
to take down Trump.
We notice that as conservatives.
And you know, so go
all the way through.
Then all of a sudden, there
were all kinds of irregularities
in that election,
there just were.
That's indisputable.
But you couldn't
talk about them.
If you did, now you're one
of the insurrectionists,
which by the way,
there weren't thousands
of armed insurrectionists.
I'm the guy that
asked the FBI witness
at the Joint Senate
Committee, okay,
if this is an
armed insurrection,
how many guns did
you confiscate?
I had no idea.
She might have told
me 1000, you know.
Zero is what she told me.
- Right, right, right.
They also didn't have plans.
That's what I kept saying.
Was there anyone with a piece
of paper that had a plan?
- Also, we saw
the video that day
of people walking between the
rope lines in the Capitol.
That's not what an armed
insurrection would look like.
Plus we were back in
business in a few hours.
I didn't see any
fires being started.
So again, listen, we all
condemned the violence.
It's tragic that
that happened, okay?
But the vast majority
of people that came here
on January 6th were here
to protest peacefully,
exercise their First
Amendment rights
to petition their government.
They are not
domestic terrorists,
and yet they're being
treated as such.
And now we're seeing
this multiple tier
system of justice we have
where the Justice Department
and the FBI are putting
record number of resources
to persecute and
prosecute individuals
that weren't
engaged in violence,
but just to make
an example of them,
while at the same time
they're completely ignoring
by and large, the 570
riots that occurred
during the summer of 2020,
2000 law enforcement
officials injured,
a couple of billion dollars
worth of property damage,
a couple of dozen people
killed during those,
a couple of people
killed in Kenosha.
We're supposed to ignore
that and focus all
on one day of rioting,
which we all condemned.
- You could also go out
and protest without a mask.
- What members of the left
are condemning all the riots
in the summer of 2020?
- No, they were condoning them.
- Well, they were
encouraging their followers
to bail out the rioters.
- Yeah.
- Again, the double
standard drives us nuts.
That's what I was pointing
out to Chuck Todd.
You know, you were so blatantly
unfair, so blatantly biased.
That inflames the situation.
You're the one
lighting the fuse here.
If the press were
fair and unbiased,
I think our politics
would be a lot calmer
and a lot less divided.
- Do you think anything's
shifting there?
So for example, you go
on, you fight him back
rather effectively,
that clip goes viral,
and then I think a
certain amount of people
do wake up a little bit
and they go wait a minute,
wait a minute, Chuck
Todd was acting
like a Democrat lawyer here,
not an honest interviewer.
So does that show you that
something's shifting at all,
or is that a little Pollyannish?
- Well again, I think
truth has its own power.
The problem is the truth is
being suppressed and censored.
What I've been telling
audiences recently
is I don't think the
conservative movement
has really grasped how
pervasively and effectively
the radical left has
infiltrated every institution,
not only of America,
but globally.
It's not a fair fight, it's
not a level playing field.
I mean, the massive stroke
in the U.S. for the left
was they took control
of the university system
during the Vietnam war
protests in the '60s.
So now they control
colleges of journalism,
so they're cranking out a
bunch of radical leftists,
advocates, and education.
And that is where they really
are exercising their power.
So now what we are
pushing K through 12 is,
it's obscene in
some cases, okay?
We're trying to
tell little boys,
maybe you're a little
girl, or vice versa.
I mean, you don't
do that to children.
Listen, we have compassion.
I understand there are
people that are conflicted,
and we have all
kinds of compassion,
we want to help folks like
that, but at this point in time,
all of a sudden
transgenderism's just exploding
in our society.
I don't think it is, I
think it's being pushed
on our society, and again,
I don't think I've said this
on camera before, but
the fact that we have
doctors and nurses that
are mutilating children.
I mean, that's a serious
operation as an adult,
to be that, I guess, tormented
that you actually undergo
a sex change operation.
I don't see how any adult can
approve of that for a child.
I don't see how you can do that.
- Did you see the clip, I
think it was about a week ago,
where somebody unearthed
a clip of Rachel Levine,
you know, the Deputy
Health Secretary, whatever,
where he/she,
whatever, says that,
I hate this pronoun
thing, it's so annoying,
but he basically
says that he's glad
that he didn't have a sex
change until after he had kids
because his kids are
the love of his life.
And at the same time
now, he's saying kids
should undergo these surgeries.
- He's pushing that,
again, for minors.
Can a minor get a tattoo?
- A minor can't drink.
- Again, there's a reason that
we protect minors that way.
Again, counsel people,
that kind of thing,
but don't push it on them,
and don't mutilate them.
It's irreversible.
Now, of course, there are some
celebrated cases of people,
transgender individuals
who had the sex change
and would kind of like to
get their old gender back.
- Yeah, it's a huge
movement right now.
- It's so hard to watch.
I mean, my wife, she's always
looking at these things,
and she wants to
show them to me,
and I'm like, Jane,
you know, please don't.
It's too awful to look at,
it's just too tortuous.
- So when you talk to, or if
you talk to your colleagues
on the other side
about this stuff,
and this is what I ask
literally every Republican,
do the Democrats
pushing it believe it?
- First of all, I don't
talk to them about this.
No, I mean, again, I think
this is the first time
I've ever been
recorded talking about
this is mutilation of children.
I talk about it,
and we're just doing
a bunch of events this weekend.
I'm talking about, Jordan
Peterson came to Senate lunch
about half a year ago,
and the point he made is
conservatives are just terrible
at defending
conservative values.
Then he granted us
immediate absolution,
he said because we never
thought we'd have to.
Whoever thought we'd have
to defend the benefit
of having a mom and a dad?
Listen, there are
other ways, okay,
but can we at least
acknowledge it's really nice
for children to have a father
who provides discipline
and the mother, again,
that's a good arrangement.
It's stood the test of time.
We never thought we'd
have to defend that.
We never thought our daughters
would have to compete
against biological males, then
be expected to take a shower
in the same locker room,
and then have judge order
the biological male
to take showers
in the girls' locker room.
Never thought we'd be pushing
back on school administrators
that want to administer
gender blocking drugs
to our children and
not tell the parents.
And then I literally
go on to say,
and this is very
uncomfortable to talk about,
but I never thought, I mean,
I revere doctors and nurses.
They saved my daughter with
a serious heart defect,
open heart surgery at
the age of eight months.
I never thought I'd
hear doctors and nurses
would actually
mutilate children,
because that's what's happening.
I mean, what else
can you call it?
I mean, you take away
your God-given body parts.
Again, as an adult, I
guess that's your right.
Nobody should have the right
to approve that for a child.
- You know, it's interesting,
I don't know if you know,
but I toured with Jordan
Peterson for a year and a half,
we did about 120 shows in
20 something countries.
- Oh, so you know who he is.
- So I do know who he is.
The reference didn't
go over my head.
But one of the
other things he says
about the transgender
issue is that he says
even for the people
that clinically have
gender dysphoria,
that truly at the end believe
they are in the wrong body,
just switching the
body parts doesn't mean
you're gonna be happier or more
fulfilled on the other side
because you often
end up with a series
of other health problems
and psychological problems.
- I think studies have
shown that it doesn't help.
Again, that's unfortunate.
Listen, we all have
compassion, we do.
We have compassion
for people like that,
but let's not force
that onto children.
I mean, kids are kids.
You can throw all kinds of
weird ideas into their head.
You can destroy
children if you're not
educating them properly,
and I would say
that pushing
transgenderism on children
is not educating kids properly.
- So let me, let's just go
deep into a couple of things
because I can sense you're
not holding back here.
And you normally don't,
so I'm not surprised.
- So you know, I got real.
- I can pull a
Chuck Todd on you.
- So listen, I got re-elected.
It's obvious, I did
not want to run again.
I am so sick of the
dysfunction of this place.
The primary reason I ran
again was because nobody else
was advocating for
the vaccine injured.
I could not turn
my back on them.
But having won
the six year term,
what I've dedicated myself,
and I tell crowds this,
I am dedicated to
tenaciously pursuing,
uncovering and
exposing the truth.
Pick your area.
What is the truth?
- All right, so let's do it.
So this administration, to me,
seems either the most
generous version of it
would be that they are
sort of willfully ignorant
of economics and reality
when it comes to science,
gender, COVID
vaccines, whatever,
or they're actually malicious.
I'm veering toward the
malicious at this point,
that they cannot be that inept.
Do you think that that's a
fair, is that a fair premise?
- So I was able to spend some
time with David Horowitz.
One time I went out to
one of his events, okay?
- I know what his
answer would be.
- So I'm talking to
him, I go, so David,
you were a communist, your
parents were communists.
He saw the light when
his communist buddies
murdered somebody.
I said, so what is
it with these folks?
What are they thinking?
I mean, they see where
socialism, communism
has been tried in the past,
it's failed miserably,
didn't work economically,
resulted in totalitarianism,
tens of millions
of people murdered.
I mean, what don't they get?
He said, no, they're utopians.
They just think if you
give them the power,
they're smarter and better
angels than the Stalins
or the Castros or the Chavez's.
Just give them all the power.
So I mean, I guess I'll
take them at their word.
They're do gooders that
think they're utopians,
they think they're
just so much smarter.
And of course, obviously
by extension, we're stupid.
We can't be expected
to live our own lives.
I mean, we will
destroy the planet.
So they're gonna be
the better angels
that are gonna tell
us exactly how we need
to live our lives,
how many times,
what kind of cars
we ought to drive.
Never mind the fact
that we don't have
the rare earth minerals
to produce the batteries
or the generating power to,
you know, it's all insane.
I mean what policy
of the left works?
- I don't know.
- I can't think of one.
I mean, their
economics don't work.
I mean, a dollar that
you held at the start
of the Biden administration
is worth 87 cents today.
That's a pretty rapid decline
in the value of the dollar
you held in your savings account
in a little over two years.
- But I thought it was the
Inflation Reduction Act.
Doesn't that mean it
reduces inflation?
It's so brilliant.
- So now you had Goldman
Sachs do a study,
published in the
Wall Street Journal,
or they wrote a
column on this saying
that the $300 billion
of tax credits
for the green
energy boondoggles,
it's really gonna cost
about $1.2 trillion.
And of course Janet Yellen's
before our Finance Committee
a couple of weeks ago, and
I asked her, I laid out,
listen, these bank failures
obviously are caused
by the inflation caused the
Fed to increase interest rates
which devalued the bonds,
put them into bankruptcy.
Let's talk about inflation.
From my standpoint, there
are three primary causes.
Massive deficit spending,
that's the biggest one,
and of course your war on
fossil fuel doesn't help,
driving up the cost of energy,
and then of course the
supply dislocations
from these idiotic
shutdowns, right?
She came back, oh, I don't
think deficit spending
is a major cause of inflation.
It's like, what?
- She says that, so right.
She also said inflation
was transitory.
But when she says that,
do you want to say to her,
well, do you understand
basic ECON 101?
I mean, like.
- Well, unfortunately, you
only have five minutes,
which is a real
problem with hearings.
You can't get into a
back and forth dialogue.
You've got five minutes,
you've got to figure out,
which is one of the
reasons I like my events,
like on COVID-19,
a Second Opinion.
I mean, I'm there and I
can ask as many questions
for as long as I want to.
And you actually
have a good dialogue,
you make sure it's
a good dialogue.
But no, I was pretty
well shocked by that.
Again, I don't think
the public understands
basic economics, but
it's kind of frightening
when the Treasury
Secretary doesn't really,
or won't acknowledge the harm
that all this massive
deficit spending has caused.
You know, again, now
we're concerned about
the money supply.
That was the problem in
the Great Depression,
is foolishly they allowed
the money supply to decline,
to be reduced, which probably
took a really bad recession
and turned it into a how
many year depression.
So we need to
understand these things,
but we need to be honest
and transparent about them.
- So what would you have
done if you were in charge
of the Fed and they
tell you, okay,
Silicon Bank is going down,
Silicon Valley
Bank is going down,
and this could trigger now
20 other banks to go down,
and then that
triggers the big one.
What do you do?
- Well, first of
all, I wasn't voting
for all this deficit spending,
so I don't think we'd
have the inflation we had.
But you know, in that
particular circumstance,
let's go back 2008/2009.
What I would have done
there is I would have said
we're gonna suspend
this mark-to-market rule
because it's destroying
these banks for no reason.
The mortgage-backed
securities weren't worth zero.
You know, I know the market
froze so nobody could sell them,
so in effect short term
they were worth zero.
By the way, I asked one of
the Federal Reserve presidents
recently, I'm not
gonna name him,
I said, did we ever determine
what percent of value
those mortgage-backed
securities had,
and I don't think anybody's
done a study on that.
But it's probably about 90%.
- Right.
- But we forced banks
to mark all those assets
down to zero, put
them into bankruptcy.
Well, the same thing
kind of happened here.
Held to maturity, those
bonds will be worth,
you know, full value, but
because of the duration risk,
they had to write
those things down.
What I would have done is I
would have come into the Fed,
and I would have opened
up lending authority
to the depositors, where
okay, we're not gonna have
your deposits held
up in a bankruptcy.
You can borrow against that
up to a certain percent.
Pick your number, 80, 90%.
- Basically so they
could stay in business.
- So they can stay in business.
But, you know, if they were
so stupid and negligent
not to have sweep accounts,
people realize, okay,
my deposit only insured
up to 250,000 bucks.
When I had my
manufacturing account,
we also had a
compensating balance,
so I was taking probably
a risk above that,
but beyond that compensating
balance for the things,
it would sweep into
overnight CDs or whatever.
- So there is a way
to maturely do this.
- There's a way of doing that,
and people weren't willing to
do it so for their negligence,
for their stupidity, they
should take a haircut as well.
I mean, obviously the
shareholders are wiped out.
That's capitalism.
If you don't have a
consequence for stupid
and risky behavior, well
you just get stupider
and more risky behaviors.
So the way the Fed has
done this, and by the way,
do you think they would
have bailed out depositors
if those depositors
were, oh I don't know,
oil drillers, refineries
or gun manufacturers?
So no, these were all the
little woke businesses
in Silicon Valley.
They were doing everything,
you know, green energy.
You know, these businesses
probably never made money.
- [Dave] Right,
they're tech start ups.
- Were probably
going through cash
sooner than they needed to.
So again, all the way
around, the way the Fed
has handled this
has been mismanaged,
and what it'll probably do
is it will probably hasten
the next banking crisis
and make it worse.
Good job.
- Is that sort of what the
Fed wants, do you think?
Again, going to sort
of the maliciousness
versus incompetence
thing, to me it seems
like the Fed always
wants to get bigger.
The machine just wants
to get bigger, right?
So okay, the more big
things that we have
that are too big to fail, we'll
just keep making them bigger
and then there'll be one bank
and it'll be in this town.
- I mean, yeah, there
are people saying
this is just the game
plan, the strategy,
to move toward a central
bank digital currency,
which would give me
cause for concern.
You know, it's long past
arguing whether or not
we should have a
Federal Reserve or not.
I think that's been decided.
They're not going to go away.
But you're far better off
with decentralized power.
You're far better off with
a lot of smaller banks.
Now, you do need some big banks,
do the big international
transactions
and do things that,
big businesses too.
Some things only big
businesses can do, okay?
But what I've seen, for example,
my plastics manufacturing plant.
When I started that business
in late '70s, early '80s,
we probably had a couple
hundred potential customers.
My guess is that's shrunken
down to about 12 major ones
because everything's
consolidated.
All these little
individual manufacturing,
plastics manufacturers,
thermoformers and stuff,
you know, great
little businesses
for little towns and
stuff, they get gobbled up,
and that manufacturing
goes from there
into a much larger plant.
That's not good.
It's small businesses that
are the engines of innovation
in our economy and provide
the kind of competition
you really need in a
competitive system.
So I don't like to see
all this consolidation.
I think that's something
that the federal government
does have a role to play
in terms of anti-trust.
I think we need to re-think and
re-work the anti-trust laws.
It's all around
benefiting the consumer,
and that makes sense,
but how do you handle
these big tech social media
giants where it's all free?
So it's almost impossible
to prove consumer harm,
but I think you can
prove societal harm.
When you start seeing
the cooperation
with government officials
to censor information.
I mean, something has
to be done about that.
But you've got Democrats won't
help us legislatively on that
because it plays
to their advantage.
- Is that the weird thing,
that we find out things
like the Twitter files where
we know without question
100% proof positive the
government was coordinating
with Twitter and Facebook,
Psaki even admitted it
a year and a half ago, but
nobody cared about Facebook,
that they were censoring people
at the behest of the government.
It's a violation of
the First Amendment.
That's basically it.
But the show just goes on.
- Well, you're seeing
the mainstream media
screaming about that, right?
Oh, I guess we're not.
- No, exactly.
- That's the problem.
So we know about it,
Fox News covers it,
a couple of
conservative outlets,
but by and large the vast
majority of the American public
is completely unaware
of what happened there
because they're being distracted
on their little news feeds
by the Kardashians or
whatever you're getting.
- Is that the push and
pull that you always
have to deal with as a senator,
that you probably could
get more done on the ground
just focusing on
Wisconsin, but you're part
of the federal machine too
obviously as a senator,
so it's almost distracting
from where you can get
concrete things done?
- Well again, the things
I want to get done
are reduce the burden of
the federal government.
So when people come
into my office,
if you're looking for
a government handout,
probably go to the Democrat
senator from Wisconsin.
If you're looking to help get
the government off your back,
you've come to the right office.
So I'm here, you
know, trying to uphold
the vision of our
founding fathers.
Yeah, we need some government,
you can't live in anarchy,
you can't live in chaos, so
you need some government,
but it needs to be limited.
Because our founders, they
came from tyrannical regimes.
They realized as government
grew, their freedom recedes,
and let's face it, freedom
is the essential ingredient
in America.
It's the freedom that people
use to dream and aspire
and build and create this
marvel we call America.
It's not big government.
Big government
crushes those dreams.
Big government takes
away that freedom.
So my goal here isn't to bring
home the bacon to Wisconsin,
my goal is to shrink the size
of the federal government
so Wisconsinites can aspire
and dream and build and create.
- Let's do a couple of
other of the big ones.
This Ukraine situation,
which we are,
I think it's around
$160 billion now.
It's weapons, it's
not a declared war,
but at some point,
in my opinion,
if you're funding a war
forever, you're kind of at war.
I think you're pretty much
in the same spot as that.
What do you make of this?
Is there any off ramp?
Every week we have
spokesmen telling them,
no, there'll be no negotiation.
I mean, it's all very
bizarre, to say the least.
- I'll give you a little
more fulsome answer
because I think it requires one.
Yeah, I was chairman of
the European Subcommittee
on Senate Foreign
Relations, ranking member.
I've probably been
over to Ukraine
as much as just about
any of my colleagues.
I was at Poroshenko's
inauguration.
I was the only member of
Congress at Zelenskyy's.
Zelenko's the doctor that ...
Yeah, so it was
Zelenskyy's inauguration.
I thought he was the real deal.
I know the Ukrainian people are.
They want to shed themselves
of the legacy of corruption.
And to describe it for you,
his prosecutor general,
when I was over there,
he said let me describe
corruption in Ukraine.
We have something like 22,000
prosecutors in Ukraine.
We don't pay them well,
but they live like kings.
I mean, that's the
endemic corruption.
Okay, so the Maidan,
that was a scream.
We want what you
have in the West.
I mean, I have nothing but
sympathy for that, right?
I have nothing but
sympathy for a country
and for its people
that are invaded
by an evil war criminal,
and that's who Putin is.
Okay, so I don't want to
give any aid or comfort
to Putin whatsoever,
and I want to support
the courageous
people of Ukraine.
But I think there
was certainly a way
of preventing that
invasion to begin with,
but not under Biden
obviously, okay?
So once invaded, once the one
opportunity we might have had
when Russia felt a resistance
because of the courage
of the Ukrainian people
and the support of the
West, which I supported
that first tranche because
partly we had to replenish
our munitions, that
the Commander in Chief
can just deplete our stockpile,
so we had to replace
those as well.
There was a moment in time,
it was a glimmer hope,
where maybe Russia
would say, whoa,
we bit off way more
than we can chew.
Let's return back
and let's end this.
But that was quite a while ago.
Now the reality of
the situation is
you don't have a
fair fight here.
Putin can continue to
send in cruise missiles
and bomb population
centers, infrastructure.
I mean, this war just
continues to grind on,
and just more and more
of Ukraine is destroyed.
Now, both sides are
losing individuals,
but certainly when I've asked
people in the State Department
well, what's the public
opinion polls in Russia?
They're highly
supportive of the war.
Well, why wouldn't they?
They've got Putin's propaganda.
They're not getting
their cities bombed.
So it's a completely
unfair fight.
There's no way Putin
gives up on this.
There's no way.
It's existential for him.
So it's a reality I hate,
but at some point in time,
everybody's gonna have
to face the reality.
Every day that this goes
by, the eventual outcome
just gets worse and worse
and worse and worse.
It doesn't get better.
- So when you hear our State
Department or even Biden
saying the Ukrainians
don't have to negotiate,
which is what they've
said repeatedly
over the last couple of weeks.
I mean, what do
you make of that?
- How does this get better?
Give me a scenario in
terms of where we turn
this thing around and you
end up with a better result
than what you have right now.
If you were to just
stop fighting right now,
how does it get better
by continuing to fight?
Again, it's a horrible reality.
I hate saying this because
I don't want to give
any aid and comfort to Putin.
I guess I would just ask
everybody, including Putin,
right now this is a
lose-lose-lose situation,
other than maybe
China wins, okay?
But I guess I would
just ask everybody
to kind of temper
what they're thinking.
We shouldn't be
contemplating going to war
with either Russia or China.
There's no good outcome on that.
- [Dave] They're kind of
coming together right now.
- There is no good
outcome on this.
I mean, we've got to recognize
the reality of the situation.
I mean, China is growing
their military, their navy.
They get a lot more
bang for the buck,
what they spend on military.
So again, it's maybe not a
reality I like to contemplate,
but it's a reality
you have to accept.
- So I mentioned that I saw
you a couple of weeks ago
at this blueprint
event in Florida
that Governor
DeSantis was holding,
a bunch of governors and
senators and Congress people.
Obviously a lot of your
message definitely resonates
with the Trump side of things.
What do you make of
this push and pull
over the last week or so?
What's going on there?
- Well, I've always
been a firm believer
in Ronald Reagan's
11th commandment,
and I've always thought,
no matter whether it's for
a school board position or
a primary in a state race
or for a national one,
your best strategy
as a candidate in a
Republican primary
is show Republican voters
how you would defeat
the radical leftist you're
gonna be running against.
Show people what you
bring to the table,
your qualifications, and
don't denigrate the other guy
or gal who just might
be our candidate.
Because it's a team sport, and
whether you're the candidate
or somebody else is, we
want that eventual nominee,
Republican or conservative
nominee, to win.
Yeah, and by the way, talking
to enough Republican voters,
most people agree with that.
They want to hear the
positive things about you.
They want to hear the negative
things against the Democrats
and the radicals, okay?
How are you gonna defeat
the Democrats, as opposed to
how are you gonna rip
your Republican opponent.
So I just personally don't think
that's a particularly
good strategy.
- Yeah, I keep saying
to people the two things
that I'm looking for and
that I think my audience
is looking for are competency
and the ability
to communicate it.
You give me those two,
even if we disagree
on some of the periphery, it's
like that'll be just fine.
Would you say you're hopeful
that we can turn this America
back around to what these
guys were fighting for?
- So I would say that normally
when I start out speeches,
I just warn audiences I'm not
the most uplifting individual.
- I heard you say
it at the dinner.
- I'll say too you're
much better off getting me
as a speaker where there
are cocktails around,
kind of take the edge
off a little bit.
- We can make that
happen right now.
- You know, again,
I'm big into reality.
I come from a
manufacturing background.
It doesn't do you any good.
You can't solve problems
if you're not willing
to acknowledge that
you have a problem.
Deluding yourself is
never a good strategy.
And I've been pointing
out to audiences
that Venezuelans voted
themselves into poverty.
An oil-rich nation, a successful
South American nation,
one election, they
voted themselves
and put themselves on
this destructive path.
Right now, America's on
a very destructive path.
Again, picking up the theme
that conservatives haven't
truly grasped how
effectively and pervasively
the left has infiltrated
these institutions.
You know, our eyes are open,
we think we see the truth.
This just looks, like
Governor DeSantis said,
this is normal versus crazy.
We know we're normal, okay?
- (laughs) Right.
- But we have to
understand this crazy
has not been defeated.
If anything, it's
still on the rise.
- [Dave] You've got to
give the devil his due.
- Okay, so we're gonna
have to devise strategies
on how can we effectively
push back on this,
because all this stuff's
being done on the radar.
Obviously the left is
teaching our children
critical race theory, obviously.
Obviously they're pushing
transgenderism on our children.
They'll never admit it.
Quite honestly, it's
only probably COVID
and online learning that
brought it to the surface
and brought it to the
attention of parents.
The pandemic was an awakening
for a certain percentage
of the population, but
probably not a majority.
And again, the
majority of Americans
still get their news
from legacy media.
They're not gonna be
talking about this stuff.
I mean, you don't see "60
Minutes" leading with an expose
on transgenderism being
pushed on our children,
or critical race
theory inflaming the
divide between racial-
- No, they'll actually
do a lie, a hit piece
about someone pushing back.
- I mean, right now we've got
a Wisconsin Supreme
Court race going on.
It's crucial.
I mean, the left realizes
because this will flip the court
if the radical leftist
judge wins this thing, okay?
So the left realizes
that, that she'll become
a super legislator, and
the Wisconsin Supreme Court
will become a super legislature,
and they'll overturn
whatever gains we've got.
They'll redistrict, and we
may lose two House seats.
And so the left is pouring
millions of dollars
into this race.
There are credible charges
against the liberal
justice, okay?
She married, when she
was young, an elderly,
I think it was a judge.
She apparently had
a drinking problem,
abused him, elder abuse.
These are credible allegations
from people, a stepson,
other people that are
willing to put their name
behind this stuff.
You know, freely uses the N word
in her official
capacity in the court.
Now, what I was saying.
- The fact that I haven't
even heard about this at all
tells me everything
you need to know.
- Precisely.
No, if those credible
allegations were attached
to a Republican candidate,
local news stations,
they'd be breaking to
the first moon landing
to bring you this
important news.
Instead, what local news is
doing is they are covering
the fact that she is
saying she's gonna sue
these journalists
for defamation.
So again, you're completely
marginalizing the charge,
and you're not
covering the charges,
you're just covering
that she's being defamed.
So again, it's not a fair fight,
it's not a level playing field.
And the sooner we come
to that realization
and start developing
strategies around that,
it's the only hope we do have.
But no, I'm not the
world's greatest optimist.
When I hear some
of my colleagues,
oh, I'm a big optimist,
well okay, you know.
- (laughs) Good luck with that.
- Where is your head?
- I always say to people
I'm a world weary optimist.
I don't think, and I
suspect you probably are too
in a certain way, that you
probably couldn't really do this
every day if you didn't believe
you could affect change, right?
- Yeah, well I'm not
giving up obviously, okay?
I mean, again, I have to believe
the truth has its own power
which is why my dedication
over the next six years
literally is pursuing,
uncovering and
exposing the truth.
- All right then, I've got two
more for you in short order.
If your phone rings and
it's maybe one of those guys
that we talked about earlier,
either Trump or DeSantis
or maybe somebody else,
and they say, hey,
I could use some
help here, you know,
VP, something like that, does
that have any interest to you?
Clearly you're a fighter.
I mean, that's obvious.
- I would not expect that.
Maybe in helping out
in the administration.
Listen, if you get called
on by a president elect
or something like that
to serve your country,
I mean, that's the thing
I was called on here.
That's why I did it.
That'd be kind of
hard to turn down,
but I certainly don't
expect to be offered
something like vice presidency.
- Then I've got one more.
If your phone rings
and it's Chuck Todd
and he says do you want to
do "Meet the Press" again,
what do you do?
- Absolutely.
The last time I was on
there, Chuck was saying,
it's hard to do this remotely.
Well, bring me in
the studio, Chuck.
Just pick up the phone.
- Was it their offer
to only do it remotely?
- Well, I wasn't
available, but I offered
right on there, let's do it.
The phone hasn't rung yet.
So he had me on and it kind
of blew up after January 6th.
It was two years later,
it blew up again.
It wasn't my intention
to blow it up,
but at some point
in time, you go-
- So you're looking at a-
- Every two years, you know,
I've got a regular gig on
"Meet the Press", I guess.
But no, listen, I'm
not afraid to defend
what my beliefs are.
Truth be told, I
do like to argue.
I think it's a really good
way to flesh out the issues.
And by the way, if in the end
I'm defeated in an argument,
I'll change my position.
Well, you made some
pretty good points there.
I mean, that's the way life is.
You have to have
a flexible mind,
you have to have an open mind.
I think that's one
of the things I found
most disturbing during
the pandemic still
is just the lack
of open mindedness.
It's like, here's the narrative,
here's what the COVID
cartel's telling us.
Again, the
disappointment in doctors
not primarily being
responsible to their patients.
Because I've heard the
tragedies in hospitals,
a family member's going, please
God, just try Ivermectin,
just please give it to them.
Won't do it, won't do
it, and then just watch
their loved one die.
And they couldn't
even be by them.
They were prevented
from visiting.
I mean, that has
not been exposed
to the extent it should be.
I mean, what happened in
hospitals, the loss of freedom
when you checked
yourself into hospital,
which is why a guy
like Paul Marik,
in my Second Opinion
event, just said, you know,
I hate to say it, but
the hospital's like
the last place he would go.
And again, he's a
critical care specialist.
I mean, here's a
guy, just real quick,
because it's really powerful.
You should put the link
onto my Rumble account
on the second,
but his testimony.
He was a critical care
specialist, so he's taking care
of patients way later
than he should, okay?
But he has a 50% death
rate of the other people,
because he's using
all these things.
So his death rate is
50% of his colleagues'.
So what do you think
the hospital did?
Pin a medal on him?
- Kick him out, I don't know.
- No, what they did was
they took away his tools.
They forbid him from using
Ivermectin and these things,
including vitamin C.
But they left him
with seven patients,
and this is a
powerful testimony.
So they tied my hands,
they took away my tools,
so all I could do was sit by
and watch my patients die,
including a 30 year old mother.
That's what hospitals, that's
what the COVID cartel did,
and now they're out
destroying people.
So in the end they took away
his hospital privileges.
So here's a world-renowned
critical care specialist,
really can't practice
in a hospital anymore.
I mean, they're taking away
certifications of these doctors,
suing people like
Peter McCullough,
terminating their employment.
They're gonna make
an example of them.
Of course, that's how they
kept everybody else in line.
I'm sympathetic with that.
Doctors, they spend a
decade plus getting trained,
getting their certification.
They've got $300,000 worth
of student loans to pay off.
They have to make a living,
plus they want to be
doctors to help people.
They just couldn't
step out of line,
or else they risked losing it
all, and that was purposeful.
- I can see why Chuck
Todd only does this
once every two years, but
I'll do it more than that,
how about that?
- Happy to come back.
- Pleasure, Senator.
- Thanks for having me on.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.